♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE CONTINUE OUR
COVERAGE OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR'S COMMITMENT TO REVIEW ALL
OF THE FBI, DOJ CONDUCT IN THE
RUSSIA PROBE, WE ALWAYS MAKE THE
DISTINCTION NOT RANK-AND-FILE,
NOT AT ALL.
I HAVE AN FBI FLAG PIN IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE 99.9%.
IT IS THE WORLD'S PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY BY FAR.
JOINING US NOW, SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN, LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
SENATOR, I WENT THROUGH IT ALL,
YOU HEARD THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TODAY.
WE HAVE ALREADY KNOWN A LOT OF
THIS.
BUT NOW IT IS ALL COMING OUT.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHAT DID THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SAY TODAY, HE IS GOING TO LOOK
AT HOW THIS GOT STARTED.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THEY WERE
SPYING ON TRUMP'S PEOPLE AND
CAMPAIGN, THE QUESTION WAS WAS
IT LAWFUL?
THE FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
SURVEILLANCE ACT ALLOWS YOU TO
FOLLOW HER AROUND PEOPLE THAT
YOU THINK ARE WORKING WITH A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT.
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION BY THE VERY
DEFINITION IS SURVEILLING PEOPLE
THAT YOU THINK ARE SPYING.
SO THE QUESTION WAS IT LAWFUL?
>> Sean: WAS IT?
NO.
>> WE WILL SEE.
I TELL YOU THIS, IF THE WARRANT
WAS BASED ON THE DOSSIER, THAT
WAS NOT LAWFUL.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY DID
NOT TELL TRUMP ABOUT PEOPLE AND
HIS COMPAY AND WITH RUSSIA IF
THEY REALLY BELIEVE THAT.
>> Sean: SENATOR, I READ
SOMETHING, YOU KNOW THAT
SOMETHING EXISTS THAT IS CALLED
THE GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO.
THERE MIGHT BE SOMEBODY YOU KNOW
WHEN THEY ARE.
AND IN THAT THE BULK OF
INFORMATION FOR THE FISA
APPLICATION WAS HILLARY
CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER WHEN THEY PRESENTED IT
TO THE FISA COURT, THEY NEVER
TOLD THE COURT THAT SHE PAID FOR
IT.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE COURT THAT
IT WAS UNVERIFIED.
AND WE KNOW UNVERIFIABLE,
BECAUSE STEELE DOES NOT STAND BY
HIS OWN DOSSIER.
SO THEY NEVER VERIFIED IT.
AND THEY DENIED CARTER PAGE HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS BY
COMMITTING A FRAUD ON THE COURT.
IS THERE ANYTHING WRONG WITH
WHAT I JUST SAID?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WHAT YOU SAID
AND WHAT WE CAN IMPROVE OUR TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS.
I BELIEVE THAT THE DOSSIER IS
UNVERIFIED TO THIS DAY.
I'VE A REASON TO BELIEVE THAT IT
WAS THE MAIN REASON THAT THE
WARRANT WAS ISSUED.
I HAVE REASON TO BELIEVE THAT IT
WAS NOT PAID FOR BY A POLITICAL
PARTY AND THAT THE PERSON WHO
PAID FOR IT HATED TRUMP.
I BELIEVE THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION IS QUESTIONABLE AT
BEST.
AND I DO NOT KNOW WHY THEY WOULD
NOT TELL TRUMP, A COUPLE OF
PEOPLE ON YOUR CAMPAIGN MAY BE
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS LIKE
THEY TOLD DIANNE FEINSTEIN ABOUT
SOMEBODY ON HER -- INNER OFFICE
WORKING WITH THE TINIEST.
NONE OF THIS ADDS UP.
BARR WILL LOOK AT IT.
I WILL LOOK AT IT.
HORWITZ WILL LOOK AT IT.
CAN I MAKE A POINT ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE?
>> Sean: YEAH.
>> THE MUELLER TEAM CHARGED A
LOT OF PEOPLE WITH CRIMES PAID
HE HAS THE ABILITY TO CHARGE
PEOPLE WITH CRIMES.
HE CHOSE NOT TO CHARGE TRUMP FOR
A REASON.
HE DID NOT THINK THAT HE COULD
PROVE A CRIME.
SO MUELLER CHARGES A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE WITH CRIMES PAY TO GET
SOME CONVICTIONS, HE CHOSE NOT
TO CHARGE PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
OBSTRUCTION FOR A REASON.
NOT ENOUGH EVIDENCE.
>> Sean: THE FBI UNDER COMEY
BELIEVES THAT HILLARY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN INDICTED.
IT NEEDS TO BEGIN ANEW NOW THAT
WE KNOW THE PLAYERS.
THE POLITICAL BIASES, AND THE
FACT THAT IT IS REAL.
WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS A
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS, WE KNOW
THAT IT IS LEGAL ONLY BACK
ILLEGAL.
AND DEMOCRATS CARE ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION, LOOK AT HILLARY
CLINTON'S EMAIL SERVICE.
HERE'S A THING, IT CANNOT BE
VERIFIED, MOST OF IT HAS BEEN
DEBUNKED IN TERMS OF THE
DOSSIER.
AND THE REASON THAT IT CANNOT BE
VERIFIED IS BECAUSE THE AUTHOR,
HE WILL NOT EVEN STAND BY HIS
OWN DOSSIER WHEN HE WAS PUT
UNDER OATH IN GREAT BRITAIN.
WE KNOW THAT THAT WAS FALSE.
AND COMEY IN THE SIGNING OF THE
FIRST APPLICATION IN OCTOBER OF
2016 WENT TO TRUMP TOWER IN 2017
AND THEN PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP
AND SAID IT IS NOT VERIFIED, BUT
SALACIOUS.
SO DATED COMEY LIE THEN OR ON
THE FISA APPLICATION?
HE LIED ON ONE OF THE OCCASIONS.
>> THE POINT IS IS THAT WE ARE
GOING TO LOOK AT THIS AND PUT IT
ON THE RECORD FOR HISTORY'S SAKE
AND TRY TO DETER OTHER PEOPLE
FROM DOING THIS.
IF THE DOSSIER IS UNVERIFIED,
WHICH I BELIEVE, HOW COULD YOU
USE IT TO GET A WARRANT AGAINST
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN FOUR TIMES?
IF YOU REALLY TOLD TRUMP HERE IT
IS, WE CANNOT VERIFY IT, WHY
WOULD YOU USE THE SAME DOCUMENT
TO SAY WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS
ACCURATE ENOUGH TO GET A
WARRANT?
IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE THAT
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN WAS BEING
INFILTRATED BY RUSSIANS, WHY DID
YOU NOT TELL THEM SO THAT HE
COULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT?
AND HOW COULD CLINTON GET AWAY
WITH ALL OF THIS AND NOT HAVE
ANYTHING, NO CHARGES AT ALL WHEN
THE AVERAGE PERSON WOULD
PROBABLY BE IN JAIL NOW?
I THINK IT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
A POLITICAL BIAS.
>> Sean: ANDREW McCABE, NO
DOSSIER, NO FISA WARRANT.
LAST THING, HUGE DAY.
THE ONE MAN THAT WAS ON THE
WORLD STAGE FOR MANY YEARS
ALONE, IDENTIFYING EVIL IN OUR
TIME WAS THE COTILLION FIGURE OF
A MINISTER OR NET NOT WHO, HE
WON A BIG VICTORY YESTERDAY.
>> HE IS BEHIND CHURCHILL, A
LEGEND, AND A GREAT OUTCOME FOR
THE UNITED STATES.
THE MOST RELIABLE DEPARTMENT
WITH A STRONG MAN IN A TOUGH
NEIGHBORHOOD, I'M GLAD THAT HE
WON.
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM.
>> Sean: AND NOW TRUMP AS THE
BIG SUPPORTER OF ISRAEL, ISLAM,